after the joe rogan controversy which
was all over the news obviously it's
obvious that the left is obsessed with
censorship well like i said that's the
obvious part but we want to get to the
behind the scenes controversy here about
how this censorship actually happens so
more talk let's tell you how it works
you ever notice how the liberal attack
mob they always seem coordinated and in
sync with their messaging there
they always seem to march to the same
drumbeat
at the exact time they need to
strange right you need to push a
narrative done
need to suppress a narrative done too
they all fall right in line
the reason they always appear
coordinated
is because they are
it's what one columnist in tablet
magazine called the blue stack
the blue stack what is it
it's this alliance of activists across
all major institutions big banks big
tech hollywood academia government
you've seen it liberal activists they're
power players here
and they hold key positions of influence
with the goal of pushing ideological
conformity on you and crushing your
descent
so how do they work
you know for example the government
can't well at least yet can't outright
force people they don't like off the
internet believe me but they're working
on it so instead they dispatch their
activist army to pressure major
companies to censor
facebook has demonstrated they cannot
act independently i'm hoping that this
will have had a big enough impact on the
world that they get the fortitude and
the motivation to actually go put those
regulations into place you shouldn't be
banned from one platform and not others
if you affor
providing misinformation out there
but you see here folks listen that's
just what they're doing in the open
the really frightening part here is what
else they're doing that they hope you
don't notice
in order to really silence dissenting
voices this activist army they have to
first find out what everybody's saying
and doing at all times they must get rid
of your privacy forever
while facebook has a lot of access to
information about how about you
consider how much google could know
about you tim cook recently said privacy
in itself has become a crisis
do you agree
i i think it's very very you know given
the scale at which information is
flowing
i don't think users have a good sense
for how their data is being used
hard to censor what you can't see right
in december google updated its workspace
policy giving themselves permission to
keep you from sharing your personal
documents through google drive if google
considers it a violation of their policy
so
let me get this one straight here in
order to know what's in your photos and
your personal documents google has to
look at them first
right right still think your privacy
matters
what about where and how you spend your
money as part of the democrats rescue
plan the irs is forcing third party
payment companies like paypal and venmo
they hand over details of anyone getting
more than 600 a year in business
payments
weird right why do they care about that
what about your kids they're safe from
all this right nope nope they're not
check out this article from wired the
unnerving rise of video games said spy
on you
turns out major game companies some of
which are based in china are known to
use data analytics and even facial id
tools to essentially track every
decision your kids make while playing in
other words you know johnny's parents
there might not be monitoring his gaming
habits very closely but big tech
absolutely is
but that's not all
check out this headline from cnbc
tick tock shares your data more than any
other social media app and it's unclear
where it goes that he says well maybe
they should clear that up sounds kind of
important to me
so not only is big tech watching johnny
play games here they're also watching uh
susie on tick tock there as well
meanwhile the fbi was looking into new
and improved ways to spy
here's a quote here from the guardian
fbi confirms it obtained nso's pegasus
spyware you know pegasus is yeah pegasus
basically hijacks your phone microphone
camera everything you want that in your
room you want a beacon microphone camera
sitting in your room every day someone
else can get a hold of yeah give a look
about pegasus scare the hell out of you
folks the truth is the american people
been surveilled for a long time
but now it's happening increasingly for
political reasons not for safety
listen man we've seen this movie before
governments using surveillance to target
political opponents instead of actual
criminals we've seen this over and over
is that what's happening here
where did this surveillance obsession
come from
just yesterday we learned two u.s
senators are asking the cia to
declassify details of a secret data
program that stores information
collected on americans yeah that's
that's us
what could they possibly need that for
even worse here's a bulletin from the
department of homeland security release
this week that should really frighten
everyone
the united states remains in a
heightened threat environment fueled by
several factors including an online
environment
filled with false or misleading
narratives and conspiracy theories and
other forms of misdis and mal
information introduced and or amplified
by foreign and domestic threat actors
these threat actors seek to exacerbate
societal friction to sow discord and
undermine public trust in government
institutions to encourage unrest which
could potentially inspire acts of
violence what the hell did i just read
remember what i've told you
the left weaponized the phrase
conspiracy theorist a long time ago to
label your views as a threat would fit
right into that dh model no
and now they can mark anyone who
disagrees as a possible domestic
terrorist
you don't believe me well here's what
officials are saying about the protests
in canada
it's really an insurrection it's a it's
an attack on our democracy it's an
attack on our federal government this is
right out of the trump playbook this is
treason this is way bigger this is a
group of
well-polished professional people that
are trying to overthrow the gun
the the government of democratically
elected government of this country
you still think you won't wind up in
their surveillance crosshairs well the
leftist media is already pushing a
narrative about the planned trucker
convoy here in the united states more on
that coming up this is from cnn
a dhs bulletin issued on tuesday the
state and local officials obtained by
cnn said the agencies received reports
of truck drivers planning to potentially
block roads in major metropolitan cities
in the u.s in protest of among other
things vaccine mandates for truck
drivers receive reports
they're getting reports now
how'd they receive those reports
why someone break some rule
so what does that mean for you
what if you support the truckers what if
you post online about it will the dhs
consider you a terrorist hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else